[Música]
la violencia regresó a Sudán un país
cuyo pueblo Clama por un proceso de
transición democrático al que tal parece
los militares niegan a darle paso Qué es
lo que está sucediendo recientemente en
ese país africano Pues el ejército
sudanés se ha enfrentado a un poderoso
grupo paramilitar por tener el control
de este país pese a la presión
diplomática internacional y también el
pedido de los ciudadanos determinar con
el gobierno militar de transición y
agilizar la transición hacia un régimen
democrático ambas partes se han
enfrentado abiertamente en las calles de
la ciudad de sudanesas las imágenes que
nos llegan desde jartum la capital en
donde vehículos blindados ametralladoras
aviones de guerra sobrevolando y también
ataques a puntos de importancia Como por
ejemplo el Aeropuerto Internacional de
la Ciudad han mostrado la violencia que
deja ya varios civiles y también
combatientes fallecidos Pero por qué
está disputa interna en este país
africano Pues se trata de una lucha de
poder entre el general abdel fataburán
comandante de las fuerzas armadas y el
General Mohamed hamvad dagalo líder de
las fuerzas de apoyo rápido que es un
grupo al margen de las fuerzas de
seguridad de ese país en el pasado estos
dos grupos las fuerzas militares y este
grupo militar eran aliados juntos
colaboraron en ese golpe militar de
octubre del 2021 que frustró la
transición democrática en Sudán
Cómo están entonces organizadas estas
fuerzas militares Cómo se balancean las
cargas en términos militares pues lo
vemos a continuación
250.000 soldados y más de 100 aviones de
combate el ejército de Sudán es
considerado uno de los ejércitos
medianos del mundo posee armamento
pesado 170 tanques y una flota de 7000
vehículos militares pero no posee
submarinos ni buques de guerra la
Aviación es uno de los puntos fuertes
más importantes del ejército sudanés en
su enfrentamiento con las fuerzas de
apoyo rápido Far 191 aviones incluidos
45 casas rusos zukoi mig 2137 aviones de
ataque y 25 aviones de carga además de
lanzadores a5
según el sitio web global fire Power que
se especializa en asuntos militares el
ejército sudanés ocupa el puesto 75
entre 145 ejércitos en el mundo las
fuerzas sudanesas se establecieron en
1956 cuando Sudán se independizó del
condominio anglo egipcio las fuerzas
tienen cuarteles generales y centros en
la capital jartum y en algunas otras
ciudades además en las fronteras con
Libia y eritrea donde hace monitoreos en
cuanto al equipamiento de las fuerzas de
apoyo rápido iniciaron en 2003 en
darkfurt con el actual líder mohameddam
dágalo en esa época fueron conocidos
Como la milicia yajawid y terminaron
siendo señalados Aunque nunca acusados
formalmente por masacres en esta región
occidental sudanesa el ahora Far se
compone principalmente de vehículos 4x4
que llevan una variedad de armamento
incluyendo armas antiaéreas artillería y
una unidad blindada ligera del modelo
vtr esta le da a las fuerzas de apoyo
rápido flexibilidad en el movimiento
dentro de las ciudades
así las cosas está Sudán Entonces al
borde de un conflicto interno era
previsible que esta disputa por el poder
estallara en cualquier momento porque
los militares entonces están saboteando
la transición democrática de este país
que respuesta puede dar la comunidad
internacional ante los hechos recientes
estando completamente desbordado eso sí
Hay que decirlo la comunidad
internacional está desbordada con los
múltiples conflictos y tensiones que hay
en diferentes partes del mundo Ucrania
yemen Siria los problemas de los
migrantes tanto en el Mediterráneo como
en América Latina en fin la lista es
larga por eso hoy en el debate pues
analizamos Cuál es la situación que se
está presentando allí en Sudán en África
para analizar este tema hemos invitado a
Jesús Romero cote él es analista
internacional colaborador en puerta de
África y se conecta desde la ciudad de
Sevilla en el sur de España y desde la
Ciudad de México se conecta Rubén Peña
él Es doctor en ciencia políticas y
sociales es investigador del Center
África han Oriental Stories de la
Universidad de atizaba en Etiopía y del
centro de documentación de la unión
africana ustedes nuestros televidentes
también pueden ser parte de este debate
pueden dejar sus comentarios y sus
preguntas a través de las redes sociales
nos encuentran en Twitter en Facebook y
en instagram nos encuentran allí como
arroba
franz24_es la etiqueta para que dejen
los comentarios es numeral el debate f24
todo pegado todo junto y a mí me
encuentran también en Twitter como
arroba santilogo por último les recuerdo
que todos los contenidos de este
programa están disponibles en Apple
podcast en Spotify en deezer y en TuneIn
paso entonces a saludar a Jesús son
Romero gracias por estar con nosotros
Jesús Bienvenido al programa un gusto
conversar con usted y le planteó esa
pregunta que hacía en la introducción
del programa era previsible Era evidente
que esta confrontación esta disputa por
el poder en Sudán entre estos dos grupos
militares entre las fuerzas armadas y
este grupo paramilitar iba a estallar en
algún momento bienvenido
Buenas noches
es complicado desde luego que si
atendemos a las últimas semanas Sí
porque desde la semana pasada ya el
ejército de Sudán advirtió de
movimientos de este grupo paramilitar
que se estaban reuniendo en torno en las
ciudades de norte de la capital y sí que
las últimas semanas ha habido una
escalada de tensión fuerte que ha
desembocado al final en este conflicto
desde mi opinión vamos desde lo que yo
he seguido el conflicto Yo no esperaba
un estallido de violencia por lo menos
de estas características sí que es
verdad que dentro de los propios grupos
tanto paramilitares como éxitos sí que
ha habido tensiones previas y hay
tensiones desde prácticamente que se da
el golpe de estado en 2021 pero que
llegara a este punto y que escalara
hasta un conflicto abierto por las
calles de todo el país no
la opinión de Jesús Romero desde la
ciudad de Sevilla paso a preguntarle a
Rubén Peña en Ciudad de México también
le doy la bienvenida allí en la capital
mexicana Gracias por acompañarnos hoy
Rubén y la misma pregunta como Punto de
partida era previsible la atención era
latente allí en Sudán recordemos que es
un país africano que es una realidad muy
alejada de lo que vivimos en América
Latina y vale la pena entender Entonces
si esto era previsible Y si estas dos
partes ya estaban presentando tensión y
poco a poco se acercaron hasta este
momento o punto de quiebre se le puede
llamar así
Hola buenas tardes saludos desde acá
desde la Ciudad de México sí de de la
escalada de valencia este nivel no era
previsible había habido ya atenciones
entre estos dentros por el creciente
poder político que han ganado en en
Sudán de hecho desde 2018 cuando
empezaron las protestas populares en
Sudán en contra de Omar bachill el mismo
presidente hizo algunos movimientos
políticos para empezar digamos acallar
la influencia de estos de estos dos
actores no de los militares y de las y
de las fuerzas de las FARC pero que
llegaran a un nivel de violencia como el
que se está viviendo ahora en las calles
en jartum no fue previsible y no lo era
porque suponíamos los analistas
de Sudán que no no les beneficiaba un
conflicto de esta magnitud por las
tensiones que hay en otras regiones del
país solo por mencionar el caso de
darfur de las montañas nuba o en la
misma región de bella pegado al mar rojo
entonces fue inesperado esta escalada de
violencia y me parece que así también lo
demuestra la respuesta de los organismos
internacionales y regionales en en esa
parte de África respuesta que vamos a
analizar más adelante Rubén a lo largo
del programa continuó con usted para
hacer la ronda de preguntas a la inversa
me parece importante poner en contexto a
la audiencia de América Latina sobre lo
que sucede al interior de este país en
qué es en lo que no se están poniendo de
acuerdo estas dos fuerzas militares el
ejército de esta fuerza paramilitar no
ve uno aquí un escenario en donde vea a
un grupo de ciudadanos tratando de
provocar un un cese de de permanencia en
el poder de un grupo militar no ve uno
como los conflictos habituales que ve
uno en otros en otros escenarios a nivel
internacional Aquí vemos a dos fuerzas
armadas enfrentándose por un botín
prácticamente como lo vio usted
Rubén sí la problemática es esta O sea
la gran cuestión es cómo se integran a
las FARC dentro del ejército o de las
fuerzas sudanesas a pesar de que estamos
hablando de dos grupos armados son
totalmente distintos uno es el ejército
militar o sea es la institución militar
con todas las características que esta
tiene y lo otro es una guerrilla una
guerrilla que se paramilitar que se fue
conformando en los en la guerra civil en
darfur entonces son dos fuerzas armadas
totalmente distintas ahora la
problemática de integrarlas a las
fuerzas armadas su danesas es justo esta
disputa política que tienen abdel fata y
y daglu no que tiene que ver con a
quienes van a tener lealtad esta las
fuerzas Far dentro de las del ejército
sudanés por las por el el peligro de que
haya un golpe de estado también en
posteriormente no entonces esa es la
gran disputa y como tú dices el telón de
fondo es por supuesto el el poder
político el poder político Jesús en la
ciudad de Sevilla cómo iba este proceso
de integración esto estaba haciendo
llevado a cabo en un marco de una
negociación entendemos que este país
estaba en una transición hacia un
régimen democrático Después de terminar
con la dictadura de Omar que fue
establecida en el 89 y estaban en un
proceso tratando hoy por lo menos ese es
el pedido de la ciudadanía de un
gobierno democrático esta negociación En
qué estado estaba
sí como tú dices en 2019 una coalición
de población civil con el apoyo del
ejército consigue derrocar al dictador
alguacil y comienza entonces un periodo
de transición de forma un ejecutivo que
podemos considerar el bicéfalo por un
lado hay un gobierno Un gobierno militar
una autoridad militar bajo el mando
precisamente desde el fatalburán y
después hay un gabinete civil que en
2021 derrocado precisamente por la parte
militar del gobierno a partir de ese
momento se inicia una segunda parte de
la transición que no es tanto transición
porque ha habido pocos avances pero sí
que la población ha seguido protestando
igual que protestaba en 2018 contra El
dictador ha seguido protestando contra
la autoridad militar eso ha llegado un
punto en que los militares se han
sentado a negociar con los civiles Y en
diciembre de 2022 se firma un acuerdo
para la transición política que
establecía entre otras cosas como como
ha comentado el compañero
ese aspecto de integrar a los grupos
paramilitares dentro de la estructura
del ejército Pero eso genera esa
problemática que ha apuntado el
compañero de una vez dentro del ejército
A quién deben lealtad y la cuestión del
ejército ha sido un punto clave en todo
el proceso de negociación y es qué rol
va a tener el ejército de Sudán en un
Sudán democrático en un futurible sudan
democrático porque vemos no son Sudán
sino también en otros países de África
que muchas veces son los los ejércitos
de las fuerzas militares quienes
provocan los cambios de gobierno
Entonces no tener al ejército de tu lado
o no tener el éxito completamente
controlado es un riesgo para un futuro
gobierno civil de que pueda ser
derrocado precisamente por la propia
Fuerza Armada Jesús en ese orden de
ideas y lo que puede uno ver desde este
lado del Atlántico es que los militares
en diferentes países africanos tienen un
inmenso poder y tienen una forma de
financiarse también estos grupos para en
este y en otros países no es el único el
caso de Sudán cómo está entonces la
institucionalidad Porque si este país va
rumbo hacia un proceso de transición
hacia un régimen democrático Cómo se
estaba reforzando entonces la
institucionalidad y este punto de
quiebre que ha tenido este brote de
violencia pues demuestra claramente
entonces que la institucionalidad el
gobierno del estado como tal sigue
siendo muy débil y los militares siguen
siendo los que tienen el poder y someten
al pueblo cuando deberían estar
defendiendo al pueblo aquí hemos visto
en las imágenes que llegan desde jartum
que una gran cantidad de civiles han
muerto en los combates en las calles
sí como tú dices sucede en varios países
de África sucede en Mali y suceden
burkino faso en Guinea son los militares
quienes fuerzan los cambios de gobierno
y quiénes se atribuyen la legitimidad en
el poder tras tomarlo por las armas en
el caso de Sudán no ha sido muy
diferente sí que es verdad que como
comentado antes en 2019 es una colisión
civil y militar la que derroca el
dictador pero desde el primer momento
los militares no han estado a favor de
compartir el poder ni tampoco de cederlo
y que haya un gobierno civil Por qué
Porque tener el poder Ya de por sí es
goloso pero también no es solo tener
poder es tener el control del país y
tener el control del país en el caso de
Sudán por ejemplo de riqueza minerales
mencionaba la cuestión de cómo se
financian los grupos paramilitares en el
caso del grupo paramilitar que nos ocupa
de La FARC su líder es la persona más
rica de Sudán según
los ranking y las listas que se realizan
y ha hecho fortuna gracias al control de
las minas de oro Entonces muchas veces
en África sucede que la institución
militar no es tanto Una institución
militar como podemos entender en Europa
o en otros países del mundo sino que es
una una situación de escenario en el
sentido de normalmente son leales al
hombre que les paga y eso es lo que
sucede con La FARC Y ese es el riesgo
del que hablábamos antes de integrar a
La FARC dentro del ejército muy bien las
integramos dentro del ejército pasan a
ser tropas regulares una vez que son
regulares la lealtad es al estado o a su
líder y ahí es donde está el punto de
quiebre principal en esta situación
claro y esto como usted lo explica Jesús
pues está en un punto de inicio esto no
va a tener una resolución pronta o
rápida porque hay muchos intereses de
por medio Rubén le pregunto También
usted qué análisis hace entonces de ese
proceso transición en el que está Sudán
Que tanto se había fortalecido esta
institucionalidad del Estado rumbo hacia
esa democratización claramente esto deja
en evidencia que las bases Pues no son
muy sólidas y aquí hay un juego político
muy interesante analizando la situación
de ese país y es el manejo que los dos
bandos le han dado a la comunicación con
los ciudadanos y este grupo paramilitar
ha salido a decirle a los udaneses
nosotros estamos con ustedes no Los
vamos a atacar para tratar de ganarse el
favor del pueblo cuando pues es el
ejército Sudán es el que debería estar
defendiendo el pueblo ahí también
empieza a haber divisiones al interior
de la sociedad
sí fíjese que la O sea la institución
más fortalecida
en el sistema político sudanés unos
militares y eso pues por cómo se fue
construyendo el estados sudanés bajo el
régimen de de Omar albacil que de hecho
en esa transición cuando cuando le ponen
a Omar albacil el el juego del ejército
fue de estar del lado del pueblo los que
hacían el trabajo sucio de atacar a los
opositores políticos justo eran las FARC
eran ellos los que hacían los
levantamientos y los y apresaban a las
personas y los
desaparecían eran ellos el asfar
Mientras que el ejército va a jugar ese
rol de Yo estoy de lado de lo que el
pueblo diga quieren que se vaya
Omar albacir lo vamos a hacer así y
nosotros vamos a supervisar ese proceso
de de ese proceso de transición Ah aquí
me parece que se ve más lejos una la
instalación de un gobierno
primero los militares desde que se
designa como Primer Ministro abdalá
no están dispuestos a compartir Pues el
poder y se ve en el golpe de estado que
dan en en octubre del año
2021 Y entonces ahora la problemática es
también no solamente no les van a dar
esa posición a los civiles sino cómo
hacerlo con un grupo un grupo
paramilitar que está muy fortalecido y
que constantemente va a estar amenazando
la estabilidad política del del gobierno
sudanés Entonces veo un poco lejana Esa
esa transición lo había comentado hace
un rato el compañero Jesús Romero sobre
que se había quedado como una suerte de
impase esa transición de esa transición
democrática de 2021 a la fecha y me
parece que ahora la yo la veo un poquito
más lejana respecto del papel que están
jugando las FARC y ese juego por la
disputa del poder político
entre entre el ejército y el y este
líder de las FARC que como también se
apuntó pues estos grupos le fue una
lealtad a él o sea no hay una una
lealtad hacia el estado sudanés hacia el
gobierno no sino más bien es un una
respuesta al al líder Rubén aquí el
temor que hay por parte de la comunidad
internacional Es que esto desencadene
una especie de conflicto una guerra
civil no sé si sea el término si ya es
demasiado escalado pero tal vez un
conflicto interno sobre todo en un país
que ya ha vivido una historia de
violencia bastante complicada recordemos
esa esos conflictos que hubo entre
diferentes etnias y entre diferentes
también grupos militares al interior de
el país Un gobierno dictatorial y todo
esto desencadenó la división del país en
dos en Sudán y Sudán del sur
como parte de ese proceso de
pacificación un largo proceso rumbo a la
estabilización estamos ante el inicio de
un del inicio de una guerra civil en
Sudán cómo lo vio usted me parece que
hay un riesgo muy latente al respecto de
esto y ya se están registrando ahorita
enfrentamientos armados en otras
regiones Como por ejemplo en darfur sí
se han reavivado los enfrentamientos
armados en esta región la cual desde
principios de del Siglo 21 pues ha
estado inmerso en una violencia
importante no que hay que tiene como tal
una crisis humanitaria y tal estos días
ya se han registrado nuevamente
enfrentamientos armados en la región de
de darfur y no solamente el el riesgo la
preocupación de la comunidad
internacional no solamente se queda en
esas otras regiones de Sudán sino en
toda la región del cuerno de África o
sea es un escenario es un teatro donde
Ahorita tenemos varias actividades por
eh armadas por y que pueden llevar a una
crisis humanitaria a un peor por ejemplo
todos los refugiados que cruzaron Sudán
desde el norte de Etiopía por la por la
por el conflicto armado entre el
gobierno central de Etiopía y el y el y
el grupo el gobierno regional Perdón del
tigre la
la violencia y el conflicto armado en la
República centroafricana sí Entonces es
un escenario donde se puede complicar a
nivel regional y puede afectar a los
países vecinos
y Jesús pasó a preguntarle por la
sociedad sudanesa qué tan divididos
están en cuanto a los apoyos a estas dos
a estos dos grupos enfrentados y el
apoyo a ese proceso de transición creo
que en este país por las
particularidades que tiene ustedes lo
conocen mejor que yo no es lo mismo
hablar de los ciudadanos de harton la
capital que están viviendo en este
momento el brote de violencia a los
ciudadanos de la zona Rurales donde hay
muchísimas dificultades en cuanto a la
infraestructura y que fueron también
zonas donde hubo pues muchísimas
escenarios de violencia en el pasado
pero la sociedad sudanesa qué tan
dividida está entre estos tres estas
tres líneas que se les ponen en este
momento seguir al ejército seguir a este
Grupo paramilitar Poderoso y que también
ha sometido a muchas personas o
apostarle por esa democracia y seguir
luchando por la democratización
Jesús
Jesús Bueno creo que tenemos creo que
tenemos problema con la conexión de
Jesús en las ciudades de Sevilla vamos a
retomarla en unos segundos le transfiero
entonces la pregunta a Rubén para
comenzar ese análisis sobre las
divisiones internas la polarización de
pronto al interior de los ciudadanos
frente a la situación que están viviendo
sí la sociedad sudanesa como como bien
lo lo comentaste es muy heterogénea en
cuestiones políticas Pero hay un hay un
común y que es un hartazgo respecto del
gobierno militar por qué Porque
representaba o representa
el régimen anterior al régimen de de
Omar albacín entonces ahí me parece que
los grupos políticos de de oposición van
a seguir empujando hacia la transición
de un gobierno civil que como lo
mencioné anteriormente no va a ser no va
a ser fácil porque los militares no van
a dejar este lugar este este lugar
central que tienen en el en el escenario
político en Sudán y del otro lado por el
lado de las de las FARC Me parece que la
la sociedad civil no comulga tanto con
estos grupos como le comentaba Porque
estos grupos desde el régimen de Omar
albacil eran los encargados de acallar a
la oposición política Entonces los
tienen muy bien identificados como que
son totalmente contrarios y que no no
pueden comulgar o no pueden estar dentro
de un gobierno democrático de de
transición Jesús su opinión le
preguntaba por la división en la
sociedad sudanesa qué tantos apoyos hay
hacia cada uno de los bandos
pues recojo lo que ha dicho el compañero
realmente la población civil
está cansada tanto de militares como de
paramilitares está cansada de los
militares porque entienden que
traicionaron ese espíritu revolucionario
esa Revolución inicial 2019 que iba a
acabar por traer democracia Sudán Pero
por otro lado como apunta el doctor Peña
los paramilitares fueron responsables de
acallar las protesta durante el régimen
anterior y también tienen una historia
de violencia es muy fuerte contra
comunidades sobre todo en la región de
darfurt entonces la población civil
recogía un testimonio esta tarde por
redes sociales la población civil está
acostumbrada a estas situaciones de
violencia pero no tiene nada que ver con
ellos es decir ellos quieren una
transición democrática y ya sea el
ejército o bien los paramilitares no van
a dejar que suceda Porque ahora mismo el
el establecimiento de un gobierno
democrático en Sudán es prácticamente
imposible porque gane quien gane si
podemos considerar que alguno de los dos
bandos banes va a tener en la existencia
del otro grupo La Excusa perfecta para
no ceder el poder para imponer más
restricciones y sobre todo para acallar
a la oposición y aquí los civiles están
en una situación muy complicada Jesús y
así las cosas a que se está exponiendo
entonces Sudán de continuar en esta
espiral de violencia de enfrentamientos
o que una de las dos partes triunfo en
esta disputa y se mantengan El Poder y
ese proceso de transición democrática
sigan pausa o siga siendo como ha venido
hasta ahora muy lento muy dilatado por
parte del gobierno A qué se está
exponiendo Sudán a nivel internacional y
a nivel regional
yo en ese sentido soy un poco pesimista
porque como acabo de comentar no sé
cuándo acabarán los combates pero tengo
claro que ninguno de los dos va a ser
ganador absoluto porque quien gane no va
a eliminar al rival completamente
y además estamos en un en una situación
Por ahora que son combates urbanos yo
veía las imágenes esta tarde y me
recordaban algunas a las imágenes que
hemos visto hace no tanto en Libia
entonces una guerra urbana una guerra
larga duradera y después a nivel
internacional Pues no sé exactamente
cómo se puede incidir en la situación si
hemos escuchado a toda la comunidad
internacional al unísono pedir el cese
de la violencia pedir que las partes
vuelvan a la mesa de diálogo Pero esto
ya lo hemos visto en otros conflictos y
es difícil frenar la utilidades si las
dos partes no quieren el mismo lunes por
la tarde
el ejército dijo que no iba a negociar
con los paramilitares y los
paramilitares que no iban a dejar las
armas Hasta que el ejército no se
rindiera el primero entonces una
situación que puede escalar puede
escalar no sé hasta qué punto podemos
considerarlo una guerra civil si se
mantienen los conflictos en jartung y en
las ciudades principales sí que es
verdad que se están extendiendo a otras
regiones pero habrá que ver también la
intensidad y los contingentes que tienen
cada uno de los partes en las regiones
para ver si son zonas de combate
puntuales o zonas de en las que se
estabiliza un frente o en las que haya
combate recurrente y a ver cómo
evoluciona todo y cuál es el papel que
ASUME la comunidad internacional pues
hasta el momento la comunidad
internacional lo que ha dicho es que
pide el regreso esa transición
democrática lo han pedido diferentes
organismos internacionales y lo ponen
como una condición para poder reanudar
esa ayuda económica a Sudán porque hay
que
recordar que es también uno de los
países con mayores dificultades
económicas en el mundo es un país
bastante pobre y que vivió estaba en un
proceso de reconstrucción después de
años de conflicto y de años de tener un
gobierno dictatorial Rubén pasemos a los
actores importantes de la comunidad
internacional que pueden verse
involucrados en este en este escenario
Egipto es un país muy cercano a Sudán
influye mucho en la región pero también
Arabia Saudita le importa mucho lo que
está sucediendo allí justamente por ese
intercambio de de hombres de soldados
que lleva al conflicto en yemen esto
puede generar un efecto bola de nieve
como usted lo estaba explicando porque
es inestable la región de este cuerno de
África
Sí me parece que aquí ya los actores
regionales que están participando de del
llamado al César fuego son Egipto y
Sudán del sur ambos presidentes han
estado en continuo en continua
comunicación con con Los líderes de
ambas facciones no con el ejército y con
las Farc pero me parece que la propuesta
definitiva puede venir de esta llamada
troyca árabe que tiene mucha influencia
en la política interna sudanesa y que lo
hizo en su momento en 2019 me refiero
Arabia Saudita emirato Sara en los
emiratos árabes y Egipto que pueden ahí
crear una fórmula para que se sienten a
dialogar las facciones ahorita que están
en conflicto lo que me lo que me
preocupa es que independientemente de
cuál sea el acuerdo al que lleguen Me
parece que la transición política y la
instauración de un gobierno civil en
caso de que se dé va a estar maniatado
al poder político Ya sea de los
militares que van a ser el el pilar
político en Sudán o de estas fuerzas en
el caso de que se han apoyados por
Arabia Saudita o por los emiratos árabes
dado el vínculo histórico que ya que ya
tiene su líder
Mohamed hamad con estos con estos países
del Golfo entonces esa es esa es mi
lectura Rubén Y qué hay de estos
organismos internacionales que respuesta
pueden tener
a lo largo de los próximos días por
ejemplo la unión africana también la
liga árabe Bueno ya Egipto Arabia
Saudita y también los emiratos árabes
Unidos usted ya los mencionó como países
que pronto pueden entrar a tener un un
rol destacado en en este conflicto para
buscar una solución pero a nivel
internacional a nivel continental qué
más puede suceder
sí que la unión africana Llame al que al
cc al fuego y ya lo hizo a través de
este de este organismo de de la edad que
son los que están haciendo los esfuerzos
para que se llegue pronto a un acuerdo
entre entre ambas facciones pero me
parece que la fórmula va a abrir de
fuera no desgraciadamente no va a venir
de la de La Unión africana sino va a
venir de fuera y creo que desde los
países del Golfo ya sea de Arabia
Saudita o de los emiratos árabes por el
poder político y la influencia que
tienen en en lo que tenían en el consejo
de de transición entonces me parece que
por ahí puede ir la la solución El César
fuego entre estas dos facciones Jesús
hay factores internacionales económicos
o políticos que puedan empezar a incidir
en el mediano plazo en este brote de
violencia hablo por ejemplo de
escenarios Como por ejemplo
Egipto que es un país como decía influye
mucho en Sudán Y en este momento
necesita
apoyo a nivel regional cuando Etiopía
está próxima a inaugurar esa gran
Represa en el Nilo azul que ha sido un
motivo de discordia entre los tres
países y bueno en el en el cuerno de
África Etiopía ha tenido que lidiar con
las tensiones con los países vecinos por
este enorme proyecto energético aquí
sería un momento de coyuntura en el que
un país Como por ejemplo Egipto que
también es liderado por militares entre
a negociar y a pedir apoyos y a dar
apoyos también en Sudán a su favor en
esta disputa por ejemplo solo como por
mencionar una
Sí el caso de Egipto es particular y
coincido con el doctor Peña en que la
solución va a venir de fuera seguramente
venga de esa proica formada por Arabia
saudí emiratos y Egipto o del entorno de
la liga árabe yo veo a la unión africana
con poca capacidad de mediar en este
conflicto porque tiene poca capacidad de
mediar en conflictos similares como el
de República democrática del Congo con
respecto a Egipto la intervención de
Egipto creo que es un tema complicado y
creo que no sé hasta qué punto los
militares en Sudán estarían favorables a
la intervención Es verdad que si una
intervención militar vendría muy bien
para reforzar su fuerza pero le daría a
las fuerzas paramilitares ese de ese
debate que hemos hablado antes de la
población civil a favor de quién o
Contra quién está Quién defiende a los
civiles una intervención militar de
Egipto en favor del régimen actual le
darían los paramilitares la razón en el
sentido de el ejército el gobierno que
hay ahora va en contra de la población
civil Entonces ese sería un factor a
tener en cuenta respecto a la presa del
Renacimiento etíope es otro elemento de
disputa en la región
Etiopía inaugure esa presa supone que
Egipto y Sudán van a tener una
limitación en el acceso del agua porque
si es Etiopía decide cerrar la presa el
agua no llega a Sudán y no llega a
Egipto en esta disputa sí que es verdad
que Egipto y Sudán comparten intereses
en estas y en otras muchas cuestiones
sobre todo con el fortalecimiento de
Etiopía en los últimos años pero creo
que Egipto tiene un papel muy importante
que jugar y la duda que a mí me queda es
cómo va a ser percibido sobre todo por
los paramilitares claro teniendo en
cuenta que Egipto ha prestado ayuda al
gobierno de Sudán que incluso Hace unos
días las propias fuerzas paramilitares
detuvieron a militares Egipto que
estaban haciendo prácticas conjuntas
como el ejército de
Egipto como mediador es visto como un
mediador neutral o posicionado a favor
de una de las partes en este caso el
ejército y el gobierno de Sudán Rubén
algo que Añadir en torno al papel de
Egipto y también al papel que puede
jugar Etiopía muy importante este país
la región sí coincido mucho con el
análisis de del doctor Jesús en el
sentido que me parece que en algún
momento al fatal Sí sí se va a decantar
por el apoyo a los militares
sudaneses por lo que mencionó sobre este
apoyo que quieren respecto de del
proyecto de la presa Renacimiento que ya
hasta pronto echar a andar el gobierno
de Etiopía y pero también para un
mensaje interno no O sea Egipto también
tiene ahí sus sus bemoles en cuanto a la
sociedad civil la posición política
entonces también para un mensaje interno
y también ese mensaje de el
fortalecimiento entre estas cúpulas
militares que en ambos países tienen un
un rol central en la en la política sí Y
es que una transición democrática en un
país como Sudán sería un mensaje muy
poderoso en otros países africanos que
también tuvieron problemas en esas
transiciones ustedes mencionaban a Libia
bueno Egipto se quedó con una Primavera
árabe que terminó en un gobierno militar
túnez está en un proceso que todavía no
logra despegar sería un mensaje muy
poderoso para la región que triunfara un
proceso democrático en un país africano
después de lo que han vivido me queda un
minuto rápidamente para la conclusión
Rubén sus conclusiones lo que viene para
su dan en los próximos días que podemos
estar viendo
vamos a ver Me parece que los los
enfrentamientos se van a seguir dando y
que la fórmula para que se sienten a
negociar va a venir principalmente desde
lo desde la troica árabe no una fórmula
que hagan
Arabia saudí los emiratos árabes y y
Egipto y también veo más lejano la
instalación de un gobierno civil en
Sudán desgraciadamente y Jesús su
conclusión para el cierre
muy similar a la de a la del doctor Peña
creo que es un conflicto que va a
permanecer Porque ninguna de las dos
partes por el momento ha mostrado
voluntad de Cesar los combates y que
evidentemente si ya la transición en
Sudán estaba siendo complicada esto
puede dilatarla mucho más incluso
interrumpirla de manera definitiva
Pues a Jesús Romero y a Rubén Peña les
agradezco mucho por haber estado con
nosotros hoy en el programa hemos
aprendido de política interna de sudar
un país muy alejado de la realidad de
América Latina pero eso es de las cosas
positivas y fascinantes de este programa
que nos permite ver en perspectiva
situaciones y realidades que tienen
lugar en otros países de El mundo es
todo por hoy Gracias por su sintonía en
nombre de todo el equipo técnico Les
agradecemos haber estado con nosotros la
producción estuvo a cargo de Laura
garzón y Giovanni agudelo y la
producción de invitados estuvo a cargo
de Tania Herrera Gracias Pueden seguir
dejando sus comentarios
[Música]